Ich hätte die Möglichkeit
gehabt, Julia abzutreiben.
Ich bin froh,
dass Julia lebt!
Der Down ist ein Doktor.
Er hat die Behinderung
entdeckt.
Deshalb heisst es
Down-Syndrom
Ich hatte das schon als
Baby, das Down-Syndrom.
Ich bin so auf die
Welt gekommen.
Viele sagen: "Schon krass,
dass 9 von 10 abgetrieben ...
... werden. Aber ist halt so.
Esther hat ein paar Mal
gehört: "Ja so ein Kind ...
... bringt man doch nicht
auf die Welt."
Autsch, das tut weh!:-)
Sei ein bisschen
lieb zu uns!:-)
Esther, mach die
Ohren auf!
Warum muss ich die
verdammte Suppe essen?
Du musst dir die Tische
zuhause vorstellen.
Kann man die daheim
aneinander schieben?
Ihr lebt ja nacher
richtig dort.
Und dann wollt ihr
doch beide am Pult
Platz haben.
Ja, das weiss ich.
Das ist einfach so.
Mit einem behinderten Kind ...
... hat man viel
Mehrarbeit.
Ich habe ein Down-Syndrom.
Ja!
Aber ich bin immer
noch ich!!
Normal. Also ich bin mich. Ich
bin nicht normal, ich bin ich!
Egal, ob ich das Down-Syndrom
habe, oder nicht ...
... auch wenn die Augenbrauen
bisschen gerade sind, egal ...
... ich bin immer noch
ein Mensch!!
Und ich habe auch Gefühle.
Und das müssen die anderen
auch sehen ...
... dass ich ein Mensch bin
und nicht eine
abstossende Behinderte!
Ich weiss, ich kann etwas
erreichen.
Ich kann trotz Down-Syndrom,
trotz Trisomie 21 ...
... bekannt werden als
Schaupieler.
Ich muss nicht denken, ich
möchte neugeboren werden ...
... ohne Down-Syndrom.
Das geht ja nicht. Ich kann's
nicht wegträumen.
Da sind wir egoistisch genug.
Wir wollen unser Leben auch
fertig leben.
Wir sind vorausschauend genug,
dass sich Julia nicht erst ...
... von uns trennen muss, wenn
wir hinfällig sind und sterben.